♪ ♪ ♪
- La vie est valable,
c'est un trésor;
chaque mouvement,
chaque battement de coeur.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ I would do anything for love
but I won't do that ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ ("Chariots of Fire"
de Vangelis) ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪ To my heart I must be t♪
♪ Nothin' left,
nothin' left for me to do ♪
♪ You're the one that I want ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Alegria ♪
♪ Come un lampo di vita ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- J'essaie de jouer des rôles
différents sans jamais
les composer. Je crois que
c'est la seule façon de jouer
au cinéma.
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪ ♪ ♪
- New York Herald Tribune!
- Je t'en prends un.
- C'est gentil.
♪
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Heard you whisperinininininin♪
♪ Another place, another time ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ And I love you, I love you ♪
♪ I love you like never before ♪
♪ Rhiannon ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- La douleur passe,
la beauté reste.
♪ ♪ ♪
- J'aimerais vous dire
que mon plus grand désir
est que dans les années à venir,
je puisse ainsi régner
et rester présente
dans vos mémoires.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ ♪